oh hello there
allow me to express an unpopular opinion
for a moment if I may
Labor Day as a national holiday is a
scam and I hate it
no no I'm not gonna try and steal your
get out of work free day you can rest
easy enjoying your barbeque and beer
while your boss ultimately picks up the
slack to keep your pay stubs coming in
all because some arbitrary holiday was
marketed to celebrate the working class
and you now feel entitled to it it's a
poor excuse for picking a man's pocket
every first Monday of September seeing
as I'm apparently the only one who knows
that around here allow me to explain my
opinion now Labor Day was created at a
rare moment in history where unions
actually served a purpose beyond pushing
about six-figure benefit packages in
determining which other members tires
they'd slash because of bulk card check
voting see that's because the Industrial
Revolution
unlike the Agricultural Revolution which
preceded it resulted in an economy with
a select few people at the top and then
a manual labor class and the factories
who were working very long hours just to
squeak out a living sometimes twelve
hours a day seven days a week now notice
that was an actual moment in history
unlike the fabricated one today from
entitled left to socialists who built
that the American Dream is more out of
reach than ever because they might have
to work a double shift at the retail job
to pay off their Gender Studies degree
that they think the taxpayer should
ultimately subsidize also notice that I
said manual laborers and not
working-class because the idea that
someone who owns that Factory or today
someone who owns a business or happens
to be an independent contractor is not
working is absurd insulting and
ironically any intellectual think about
it the only difference between a lawyer
a doctor an investor independent
business owner and the working class as
as the current nomenclature that the
former simply work with their minds
instead of their bodies does that mean
that their work is any less valuable
I thought the left had the corner on
intelligentsia or does that only apply
to modern humanities majors who posit
theories and philosophies that needn't
yield results in the real world but that
just mirrors Marxism to a tee after all
what gives the working class or
proletariat's the rights to have the
government violently seized businesses
and means of production from others
outside of the
at the very cerebral work required to
create it in the first place is simply
not valued in a communist Society
well we're speaking of value let's go
back to the value of time again today
most Americans are horrified to learn
that in the time of the Industrial
Revolution many people were working
12-hour days without breaks because in
the age of today the average 34 hour
workweek
who would ever consider putting
themselves through that and that's where
we come full circle today while you
enjoy your melanoma and corn beer there
are still plenty of people who work
those kinds of hours without the benefit
of a labor union they're cold business
owners you know the people you'll
inevitably find time to vilify today
between your hot dog eating contests and
waking up in a boozy puddle of your own
filth on some stranger's lawn because
while you were taking the day off to
play drunken lawn darts they were likely
working to make sure that the lights are
still on someone has to make sure that
you can find your way when you totally
stumble in on Tuesday looking for the
alka-seltzer listen enjoy your silly day
off and have fun my only point here is
that Labor Day just highlights the gross
mass generalizations that come from the
left in the 21st century even though
they accused the right of being racist
at every opportunity possible it is they
who exclusively separate and view people
through the prism of sex race age and
yes socioeconomic status this class is
amiss just another way to divide and
conquer turn brother against brother and
to make you think that you're somehow
owed something that only big brother can
provide so enjoy your labor day and
enjoy your weekends off and eight hour
work days for that matter and yes like
you'll see in all the social media
trends today you can in part thank a
union for those luxuries just know that
they're afforded to you because of
someone who enjoys none of them someone
who doesn't have a standard weekend and
has likely gone years of working
tireless and borrowing money just to
make payroll so ok for your time off
benefits and silly little end of summer
holiday thank a Union as for your job
and the ability to provide for you and
yours thank a business owner
hey if you liked this video subscribe or
hit the notification bell I think you
see some videos playing in boxes up
above but you may or may not know we've
been demonetised on YouTube so you can
actually support this channel by joining
mug club lot of credit com / mug Club
you get this wonderful handouts mug
along with hours of content every week
the full daily show that you don't get
here on YouTube also if you want to see
this with the hemp if you want to see
nip that can be on YouTube you got to
join my club nips for bug Club